dans le pays de rabelais notre
pâtissiers en herbe va enfin rencontrer
l'inventeur de la fameuse tarte du
vigneron
bonjour je cherche patrice alors il est
dans le fond du magasin dans le
laboratoire laisser aller lever voilà je
vais découvrir je pense que j'arrive au
bon endroit
patrice bonjour si pauline enchanté je
crois que vous avez quelques petits
secrets à me raconter sur la tarte
vigneron à tablier à merci je suis prête
à parer à pâtisser on y va alors dites
moi tout cette tarte du vigneron
elle est composée de quoi c'est pas tout
à fait la fameuse pâte feuilletée je
jette j'appuie un peu la pâte feuilletée
parce qu'elle me fait un peu peur ça à
faire un peu quand même
donc la pâte feuilletée de pop com et de
confit d'oie fameux profil bas tu vas la
sphère web on va essayer si demain c'est
ça c'est ce qu'on appelle la détresse
des trempes dire la farine l'eau le sel
qui mélanger le beurre on le met au
milieu par l'est et là on referme
on referme voilà près on lui donne des
tours
[Musique]
et c'est parti on étale la pac ont
l'appli en trois ans lui donne un quart
de tour et on la laisse reposer deux
heures entre chaque tour
une opération qu'il faudra répéter cinq
fois ça pour se dispenser des temps de
repos
notre chef a pensé à tout et on a
préparé une d'avancé reparti dont voici
mon flair maintenant il faut létal est à
peu près de 3 mm ok je suis consentir
c'est bien simple car le capot qui ont
lapidé carrément transpire cela à ok
alors là ça évite qu'elle gonfle trop
donc ça reste bien placé d'accord
[Musique]
étape suivante détaillé un cercle au
couteau et placer les pommes donc la up
on a terminé à bhl et l'armée confie
maintenant non c'est une confiture au
four et va ça va devenir liquide comme
de l'eau et il y aura plus rien sur la
tarte
on le met après comme une confiture
hockey une fois qu'elle est cuite très
bien d'accord
et voilà le résultat final bon voilà la
fameuse tout à fait belle tarte vignerot
elle brille elle donne envie alors bien
construit sur du bois donc il n'y a plus
que la dernière étape maintenant
vraiment à la dernière l'a goûté la
dégustation alors c'est parti
[Musique]
ça sent bon
alors tout de suite on retrouve ce goût
de tipis que c'est le vin ça revient
tout de suite oui oui c'est trop sucrés
et avec les pommes ça s'accorde vraiment
très très bien je trouve que ça apporte
le petit plus sur cette tarte et
vraiment c'est très très bon ben merci
en tout cas de m'avoir accueilli je suis
ravi de se rencontrer ben merci beaucoup
et puis ben moi je j'en profite je vais
finir voilà
[Musique]